est-ce que tu attachent de l'importance
à ce que les gens pensent de toi ça
dépend qui pensent quoi - la kabbale de
gens qui peuvent penser ce qu'ils
veulent on a lâché mais les gens que
j'aime bien ça m'apporte bon on va boire
parce que bien entendu tu t'en doutes on
est allé avec une caméra dans la rue on
leur a demandé ce qui prouve 7,3 mais
avant de lentement au risque qu'ils
pensaient toile au rabbit 2 3 trucs quoi
monsieur un truc très objectif 13
costard de stars c'est de l'info
oui
un spécial je crois qu'il est très
mauvais caractère vous êtes au courant
qu'il en soit il a une sale réputation
c'est on peut le dire une ordure un type
pas de sympathie pour dieu vous il est
carrément ça vous étonne ou pas du tout
c'est ce qu'on en dit comme je connais
pas je sais pas si c'est vrai au pain
enfin pour moi c'est pas eu leur dire
vous promettra pour moi c'est une ordure
vient de découvrir qu'il toucha le
chômage sous 19 identités différentes à
bout choc ou pas beaucoup mais monsieur
que pensez-vous de gérard jugnot
il est sympa de découvrir qu'il touchait
le chômage sous 29 identités différentes
à vous en pensez quoi
neuf mois par mois
ouais bah c'est scandaleux c'est tout
mais
non mon show ça ressemble au personnage
chaque mois ils touchent le chômage
ce 59 identités différentes je pensais
ce conteneur
cent dix-sept fois le chômage on sait de
source sûre que lors de ses dernières
vacances en espagne il a abandonné son
chien en l'attachant un arbre ça vous
choque ou pas si ça c'est pas vrai ça
vous choque vous qu'il ait violé son
chien je suis pas au courant et si c'est
vrai c'est dégueulasse mais je sais pas
quoi vous dire
accuser sans preuve
moi je dirais ça dépend ça dépend des
circonstances ça dépend pour quoi et la
c6 à un crime passionnel ou pas si c'est
par un crime passionnel
c'est pour avoir la maison plutôt
essayer de vous violez vous vous diriez
quoi je refusais enfin je t'aime un viol
c'est une atteinte à une personne ont
d'abord dû jugnot en plus c'est pas mon
genre d'être auriez vous faire violer
par quel genre de mec blonde yeux bleus
au mondial
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
zinal habitudes abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus